yes on my channel my dad  what up guys welcome to the just pearly  things youtube channel today i have two  special guests on my channel my dad and  my cousin aiden so you won't believe  what's going on today i was invited to  go do a video with  fredo bang  and because like loki he's been to jail  for attempted murder i think my dad's  going with me  yay  are you excited to go i'm so excited  does your mom do you think she's gonna  kill you after this oh absolutely  i had to run out the door being a little  youtuber is tough i'm really tired of  being broke dad a quarter mile i can't  mooch off of you forever  that's why we're going ready because  we're going in this like nice gated  community in this wow  giant van like  which makes it ski masks at this point  i don't film when i meet somebody